at the time New York felt very thriving
and it was just this crazy over-the-top
world Harris and Nikki Hilton Nicole
Richie Mortimer party giant handbags
socialize our beautiful clothes all
these photographers I just remember
thinking I want to be part of this this
looks cool
how to break into New York Society 101.
I kind of invented the Hilton sisters
well I taught them how to pose people
realize the power of image
when I met Tinsley Mortimer and we were
at a party I said it's all about being
in the right dress at the right time
Kingsley Mortimer dropped on the scene
like a bombshell
it was a new time it was kind of a
free-fall people were doing blow and
they were hanging out and they were
making the world go around I mean that
was fun until it just became not fun
when the blogging craze took off
suddenly everyday people were putting
their opinions about Amos people on the
internet blogs like Walker whereas
Hilton Park Avenue pierage an anonymous
logs devoted to who was up and who was
down who created a story Alliance off
with the villains were
they cultivated a real air of Mystery
figure the power of the pen and that pen
could be vicious and mean there was no
separation between myself and this
glamorous glittering world it was almost
like this weird secret society that was
very public there was no sense I was
writing something that would affect
someone's actual life it ended up
putting me in a place that I was so low
sorry
well that's America for you gonna bring
them up and then they bring them down I
just had a nervous breakdown there have
been plenty of socialites you know
who've died it seemed like the wild west
of media no one went higher and fell
further down it was really surreal these
were real people and not like characters
in a book we made them into characters
[Music]
this concept of Fame the concept of
celebrities I think it's a big lie
[Music]